oder was geht ab ihr sohn max und heute
gibt es leider kein video kann richtig
ist zumindest gestern kam er gar keins
heute möchte ich halt mal mindestens ein
kleines update machen damit ihr auch
wisst was überhaupt los ist gestern habe
ich an meinem seminar aber die ganze
zeit gearbeitet heute habe ich das auch
getan weil ich musste ihn 20 tagen
abgeben und ich hab halt ja vor ein paar
tagen erst angefangen bzw bin nicht
wirklich weit und jetzt wird es langsam
zeit dass ich da mal den arsch
hochkriegen deshalb bin ich da gerade
relativ viel beschäftigt und ich hatte
eigentlich was aufgenommen werde für
heute ich habe mir auf twitter fragen
stellen lassen mit dem hashtag rät x max
und da kam auch echt ein paar coole
themen zusammen leider ist die aufnahme
asynchron geworden ich habe auch so drei
versuche ab bis ich eine coole runde
hatte und jetzt ist es halb acht und ich
kann nicht noch weiter versuchen dass
irgendwas kommt bevor dann wieder nichts
kommt weil ich wollte irgendwie schon
was aufnehmen heute auf jeden fall bin
ich super zufrieden damit wie das gerade
alles läuft ich möchte mal neue designs
und so aber das habe ich ja glaub ich
schon ein paar mal angesprochen
es ist auf jeden fall nur eine frage der
zeit bis das wieder mal wird ich habe
eine capture card habe ich mir jetzt
organisiert und dann wird es bald
losgehen mit einem kleinen format was
sie geplant habt ja ich hoffe ihr
versteht das außerdem bin ich bei titan
dabei was ja im pvp projekt und ich
glaube da werden auch die pvp fans unter
euch wieder ein bisschen auf ihre kosten
kommen
ja das wollte ich euch auf jeden fall
gesagt haben es tut mir leid das ist
teilweise ein bisschen blöd ist in den
letzten tagen aber viele von euch sind
ja sehr verständnisvoll und muchas
gracias dafür
sorry